or joining me now is a retired Air Vice
Marshal Sean Bell Sean great to have you
on this topic you're just discussing
that you've flown planes that have that
have dropped these things in in the past
just quickly remind us what exactly
we're talking about what is a custom
munition yeah classification has been
around since the second world war but in
effect they are a single munition that
once it's been released then uh
jettison's a whole load of sort of
bomblets or um projectiles and scatters
them over at quite a large area in other
words it's an area weapon during the
Cold War as we were discussing the Harry
used to fly the bl755 was it was a UK
weapon had 147 bomblets in each of the
the weapons so that you can actually
pretty much guarantee to hit a tank
um with those weapons and and why then
have so many countries including the UK
ban them in more recent years probably
cluster weapons is that you're trying to
hit a tank you deliver a weapon you
deliver a football pitch size of
Ordnance definitely one or two are going
to hit the tank go through the tank and
destroy it the vast majority will not
hit the tank at all and hit the software
round and most of the little armaments
will detonate but a good proportion of
them don't and without weapon it was
about 10 didn't detonate and over the
years that means you've got unexploded
ordinance on the ground a significant
amount of it and over the years tens of
thousands of Civilian lives have been
lost and they continue to be lost as
kids and whatever dig these up play with
them and they explode as a result 120
countries ban them but of course Russia
and America and Ukraine haven't banned
them and what's the positive case then
for why it's understandable for the US
to want to give this to Ukraine well
Ukraine is desperately needs weapons
they've been asking for weapons their
spring offensive is not going as
smoothly as they would have liked
they've got trench systems and mine
systems that are holding them up and
these area weapons the US is probably
going to give more high miles very
expensive not many of them but these
aerial weapons could be very effective
and against the trenches and against the
mines and the two but they're planning
to give them artillery shells so these
are 155 millimeter artillery shells that
blow apart to have explosive grenades
inside them
um really effective they're about 80
grenades in each of the leads the
challenges of course is because they're
being going to be used on Ukrainian soil
president zielinski will own the risk
and as long as he understands the risk
of using these and the Legacy inherits
that he may make a judgment that the
benefits outweigh the risks so you can
deal with the risks long term they could
be a decisive a weapon in breaking
through the crust of Russian defenses
but there will be a price to pay as long
as he understands that he will own that
risk really very interesting as always
sure thank you